[Music]
what is life where did we come from
water is h2o two atoms of hydrogen and
one of oxygen pulled together by
covalent bonds the air we breathe is a
mix of countless particles along with
dust and water vapor then what is it
that makes up life what are the
ingredients of our fundamental essence
and what is it
that separated us nearly four billion
years ago and continues to separate us
today from everything else
oh no doubt many individuals in the
ancient world concern themselves with
these great questions it was the Greeks
from around the seventh century BC
onwards who turned it into a viable
career path many philosophers of the
Greek world the like of Epicurus
Lucretius and Plato be occupied
themselves with where life came from the
overwhelming conclusion was that life
baguettes life but what of the first
life what began that in the fourth
century BC Aristotle concluded that
living things arise spontaneously from
nonliving matter as long as that matter
contained in nuuma or vital heat worms
he surmised arose spontaneously from
decaying manure insects sprang forth
from the morning dew and eels
Servet newborn from nothing more than a
wet booze and rotting seaweed remarkable
as this may seem to us now Aristotle's
ideas of spontaneous generation
dominated thinking on the origin of life
for nearly 2,000 years the scientists
that followed in his footsteps devising
ever more complex recipes for higher
forms of life like early 17th century
Dutch scientist jean-baptiste van
Helmont who reasoned that a dirty shirt
left in a bin with wheat germ for 21
days but spontaneously generate live
mice
over time though the recipes for
spontaneous life lost favor science
advanced and explanations were found for
the seemingly miraculous appearance of
animals in old abandoned heaps of dirt
but for the smaller enigmatic creatures
bacteria and weird single-celled amoebas
spontaneous generation proved hard to
disprove finally in the 19th century
French biologist Louis Pasteur devised
an experiment to exclude any outside
influence from a flask full of inanimate
matter a vacuum when the flask remains
sterile the concept of spontaneous
generation was proved to be false matter
alone could not make life after all to
this day no laboratory has been able to
pull life from its absence Frankenstein
remains a fiction life and only life has
continued to beget life and yet we know
today that the earth formed more than
four billion years ago without life no
living thing could have survived the
convulsions of the Hadean Eon but here
we are today on an earth brimming with
overflowing with living beings of every
imaginable form and function from
rainforest to desert from the highest
peaks to the deepest ocean depths life
thrives
so it is abundantly clear at some point
between three to four billion years ago
matter did make life the final act of
spontaneous generation in history the
origin of life on earth the questions
that remain a how and from what
[Music]
the first life on earth must have been
the simplest possible life form no mice
could have sprouted spontaneously into
being on a late Hadean Eon earth in
order to decipher where life came from
we must first consider what exactly life
is at its most basic level a monumental
task requiring all the efforts of modern
scientific technique in most education
systems humans learn to define living
things by what they do animals plants
and fungi taking steps to maintain
themselves grow and reproduce but this
isn't the full story living creatures
might do these things but they're not
the only ones by this definition we
would class some crystals as being alive
or computer viruses algorithms even
today this is not the standard
definition for the origin of organic
life on Earth instead we need to zoom in
to the microscopic level to see what
living things are made of
the simplest forms of life today
bacteria have two basic ingredients a
self-replicating molecule like DNA that
contains the instructions for making
another one of itself and a
self-contained metabolism that provides
the machinery to do the living and the
replicating defined like this we capture
the essence of every living thing on
planet Earth everything is made up of
cells like the bacterial cell which at
their core have a self-replicating
molecule and a self-sustaining
metabolism this definition gives viruses
a place on the road to life - even if
they don't quite qualify these tiny
structures have a self-replicating
molecule within them just like every
other living thing but they lack the
machinery to do anything with that
molecule instead they must hijack other
organisms to borrow the organic
factories that will allow them to
reproduce some scientists would class
them as alive others would not some even
think that they may be a piece in the
puzzle of life's origins a kind of
halfway point between living and dead so
a self-replicating molecule and a
metabolism were the two inventions
needed for the very first life-forms but
they're not simple inventions
our DNA is a giant complex macromolecule
a long double strand made up of millions
of smaller simpler molecules they
themselves built from atoms of carbon
oxygen hydrogen nitrogen and many more
the modern metabolism built around this
monster molecule is a complex organic
factory to each part finely tuned to a
particular function and interdependent
on everything else
to keep running of course life couldn't
start out with something so elaborate
its beginnings were necessarily much
simpler using basic building blocks that
already existed on the early earth or
that were made for the first time inside
its young oceans so to find the true
beginning we have to go back and examine
the chemical composition of this young
world of all the possible elements in
the universe 94 occur naturally on our
planet
every element is characterized by its
behavior its affinity for other elements
and the energy needed to make or break
connections some don't react at all
others like silicon react slowly needing
huge amounts of energy to restructure
its molecules silicon is abundant on the
earth but not a good candidate for
shifting reactive biological life carbon
is a stronger choice the fourth most
common element in the solar system it
can easily form strong bonds with other
carbon atoms as well as with other
abundant elements oxygen hydrogen
nitrogen all life on Earth is based on
this cosmopolitan
element combined with oxygen and
hydrogen in what are now called organic
molecules
in fact the Hadean earth was a melting
pot of organic opportunity
sugars which were destined to become the
backbone to our genetic molecules and
the fuel for our cellular factories were
made with cosmic chemistry and formed in
the star forming regions of the Milky
Way they floated freely in the early
ocean nuclear bases to simple nitrogen
containing compounds that when combined
form the basis for information storage
in our self-replicating molecules the
molecular language of life's instruction
manual a repeating pattern of four
different nuclear bases encodes all the
instructions for how to stay alive grow
and reproduce on the early earth they
could have been a spontaneous product of
primordial chemistry finally amino acids
also ubiquitous to all life on Earth
they are the building blocks of proteins
from which almost all cellular machinery
is shaped
[Music]
to prove this back in the 1950s to
American scientists Stanley Miller and
Harold Urey designed a now famous
experiment to try and create these amino
acids from what they believed the
composition of the early atmosphere to
be they started with a mixture of water
methane ammonia and hydrogen and ran an
electric spark through that mixture on
the early earth the same conditions
could have been created by a lightning
bolt
spearing down from the thunder clouds
that capped the first mountains the
result was the creation of entirely new
chemicals including several of the amino
acid building blocks that all life on
Earth uses they proved that organic
molecules could in fact be made from
inorganic matter so the building blocks
existed as a kind of organic soup in
Earth's early oceans but this alone is
not life the molecules must come
together in a very specific way to form
self-replicating molecules and protein
machinery the key to life and therein
lies the paradox today almost all living
things use DNA as their self-replicating
molecule the patterns of nuclear bases
in the molecule encode all the
instructions for growing and reproducing
and making proteins but of course 20v do
these things it needs protein machinery
to read the instructions interpret them
and make new components it needs the
hands to do the work
so proteins are needed to read and
reproduce the DNA but the DNA
instructions are needed to make the
proteins in the first place
it's the ultimate conundrum the original
chicken and egg what came first the
proteins or DNA we are back at the
beginning our primary problem the loop
continues life baguettes life yet again
yet the true answer is probably neither
the DNA or the proteins scientists today
think that another molecule bridge the
gap the true prototype for the complex
machinery that powers our existence the
true beginning of life on earth beneath
the churning chaos of Hadean Earth's
deep oceans potentially for the first
time a molecule successfully replicates
itself
[Music]
our n a as it is known is a
self-replicating single stranded
molecule similar to but simpler than DNA
it can replicate but it can also not
itself up into 3d structures very
similar to the protein machinery used in
living things today scientists believe
RNA could have been a catch-all molecule
that performed all the functions of
early metabolism and replication the
result would have been what scientists
call the RNA world where all of biology
is made up of this single-stranded
nuclear base pattern
in the prebiotic soup random
combinations of sugars and nuclear bases
come together and are joined
spontaneously by chemical reactions some
break apart again but some stay stuck
and continue to grow into long strands
one nuclear base after another
sometimes the Strand effects its own
structure coiling or folding back in on
itself in this way a kind of pre life
natural selection takes hold to select
the kinds of molecules that are
structurally stable and mechanically
useful the stable strands can act as
templates for replication for making
another identical to itself that the
bunched up strands acting as rudimentary
machines to help that replication along
a whole ecosystem of different RNA
molecules emerges proliferating and
diversifying more stable strands
replicating more successfully floating
freely within the primordial soup
[Music]
but this too is not yet life
the RNA ecosystem alone is a fluke of
chemistry not a self-sustaining organism
any chemical imbalances in the
primordial oceans could have collapsed
and destroyed the entire RNA world even
the smallest puddle on the primordial
earth is a big place for a fragile
strand of RNA the chemicals needed for
metabolic chemical reactions being
impossibly diluted the chances of them
running into each other are vanishingly
small promising reactions all the while
being disrupted by other chemicals
floating around in the water so for
metabolism to really get going
the reactions needed a box to happen in
separated from the outside environment
where chemicals were concentrated and
where the RNA could help direct the
composition within all living things
rely on these compartments these boxes
some make do with just one others have
trillions
[Music]
just like the machinery within the
earliest cells probably looked very
different to today modern cells have
infinite variety and complexity but the
earliest cells would have been much
simpler but there's a good chance they
were made of similar material called
fatty acids these two would have formed
spontaneously from chemical reactions in
the prebiotic soup but it's their
interaction with the surrounding water
that makes them special fatty acids and
the molecular relatives have a two part
structure part is attracted to water
while the other part is repelled by it
so what does a fatty acid do when it
finds itself immersed in water it cannot
tear itself apart to satisfy both halves
of its bi-polar nature instead it seeks
solace in groups spontaneously
self-organizing into spherical
structures that shield the water heating
portions while allowing the water loving
parts to bathe in the soothing Wash
fatty acids may not have been the most
abundant molecule on the early Earth but
their spontaneous self-organization
makes them promising candidates for the
earliest protocells larger spheres could
easily have contained strands of
replicating RNA the environment inside
isolated and protected
chemical reactions can happen in this
new concentrated internal environment
they can be influenced and directed by
the RNA strands and the changes inside
influence the strands themselves the
first tentative metabolisms arise
natural selection of chemical stability
meaning that only those concoctions that
favor self-preservation
and perpetuation can stick around from
starborn atoms and molecules
concentrated on the young Earth's
volatile surface giant macromolecules
formed found ways to reproduce and pass
their success on to new generations with
survival the sole purpose in proving and
warping along the way just this one time
life arose spontaneously matter begat
life allowing life to beget life for
another three and a half billion years
and counting
next time we follow life back to its
last Universal common ancestor and find
out where on earth these first tentative
steps into biology took place we'll
explore the controversy around the very
first fossils and consider the
possibility that life itself may have
been delivered from space
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to Like
subscribe and share and let us know in
the comments what you'd like to see
covered in the future thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time